when eurydice the wife of greek god
orpheus is killed by a snakebite
orpheus falls into despair but he
devises a plan he ventures into the
underworld to recover eurydice and using
his incredible talent as a musician he
convinces hades and persephone the gods
of the underworld to agree to let her go
back to the surface but they give him
one condition until they are out of the
underworld orpheus cannot turn to look
back and see if eurydice is following
him
this video is sponsored by mubi sign up
for your extended free trial today we
tend not to think of it that often but a
film starts telling us its story long
before it even begins elements of a film
like its genre the trailer poster design
and even casting set the stage for what
we'll be watching and give us a sense of
what the story will be so when you see
that nicholas cage is starring in a film
called pig and that this is the poster
most likely you already have a strong
impression of what that film will be
about
i'm looking
for my pig
revenge thrillers have been a staple of
cinema for ages but recently a specific
variation of this narrative has been
particularly popular just last year in
addition to pig we also got nobody and
wrath of man which both riff on this
same story format but it's probably the
original john wick that best summarizes
these story tropes and which i think pig
is most directly mimicking the story
goes like this
there's a seemingly regular guy living
his life but by some chance he brushes
with some very bad dudes nice ride they
either threaten something he loves take
it or destroy it and as this character
responds to this situation we realize
he's not actually a regular guy he's a
retired assassin or secret agent or
something that makes him basically not
the kind of guy you wanted to mess with
and then you spend the rest of the movie
basically seeing exactly why you didn't
want to mess with that guy nicolas cage
has himself starred in two films that
play with this structure to some extent
prior to pig so when the film starts and
you see nick cage living in the woods
with a pig looking like this and in the
opening moments the pig is taken
genre expectations and the kinds of
roles nicolas cage have played in the
past tell you exactly what kind of ride
you're about to go on the appeal of
these films lies in the thrill of
revenge the film strikes a deal where we
get to revel in keanu reeves going
absolutely homicidal on these guys
because hey they're killers and they
kind of deserve it right
and there's a strange tension between
these figures who have usually retired
from their life as a former killer only
to be drawn back into that life that
they chose to leave good seeing you
again john their return to the
underworld is sometimes like in john
wick or in the recent bob odenkirk
variation nobody kind of celebrated
within the context of the film the
character arc is that these guys get to
flex their muscles and showcase their
top of class ability to do violence but
now their actions are justified within a
revenge ethic as a kind of retributive
vigilante justice it's about them
reconnecting with some latent part of
themselves that they've tried to bury
4.9 liter v8 he said
with the film capitalizing on the
audience's lurid attraction to watching
them re-embrace their violent past and
sometimes most explicitly in the case of
nobody this reconnection with violence
is even connected to the character's
masculine sense of self
with the character's violent behavior
revitalizing his wife's attraction to
him
so when pig invokes the genre tropes of
these kinds of films we expect violence
the filmmakers know we expect violence
everything from the marketing to the
casting to the visual style of the film
is modeled to fit right alongside the
other films in this genre pig is one of
those films that unfortunately you have
to spoil in order to even talk about
what is good about it but i really
wanted to talk about pig and so if you
haven't seen it please go watch it and
then come back and watch the rest of
this video because there are spoilers
ahead despite all the genre expectations
and the film's marketing and casting
instead of something like this
[Applause]
we end up with
this i don't think we have a persimmon
tree
no
it's okay
there are many similarities between the
two films it's not what you did son
that angers me
it's who you did it too the protagonists
have reputations as having almost
superhuman abilities in their trade
you even know his real name
both lose their wives and have
recordings of those wives voices both
give up their professions there's a
villain with a son he despises in both
yeah while you had your wife i had my
son
and believe me you had a far better deal
my son means well
but uh
he's not cut out for this business it'll
eat him alive and there are hotels that
act as gateways to the underworld both
riff on greek mythology and john wick
the hotel concierge is named sharon a
character from greek mythology who
ferries people across the river styx
into the underworld and the inciting
incident in both films involves a pet
but despite these similarities pig turns
the value system of john wick on its
head most obviously robin feld doesn't
violently overpower his enemies but
confronts them by dismantling their
value system
none of it is real
the critics aren't real
the customers aren't real
because
this isn't real and he does this in
hopes of reclaiming what was his not to
punish the people who wronged him it's
easy at first to mistake rob for someone
who cares about nothing
it's all
gonna be at the bottom of the ocean
again
who has descended into a kind of
nihilism because of his grief and
removed himself from society but i don't
think that's what he represents in the
film at all at least by the end like
orpheus robb enters back into the
underworld in search of what he's lost
the world rob enters back into is one of
artifice and image
i remember a time when your name meant
something to people robin
but now
you have no value value and even
existence are conflated with reputation
and material success you don't even
exist anymore
amir doesn't listen to classical music
like his father
the classical composers are those of the
first rank but recordings that try to
help him appreciate classical music he's
trying desperately to become his father
and to his father reputation name and
influence are what matter in their world
business is more important than family
we don't
step in each other's sails
i've got my business and he's got his
why don't you work for him
you don't know me punk
i work with your father all right
eurydice is the name of the restaurant
owned by derrick fenway on the surface
the restaurant promotes an image of
caring for the land and the environment
it's it's a fascinating and expanding
local industry with deep roots
and old world uh traditions but that
image is a shallow artifice and
underneath it is a chef desperate for
recognition willing to steal a pig from
someone else to stay competitive i
respect you chef i always have but i'm
running a business here
and people have expectations
uh critics investors
derek cooks not the kind of food that he
likes but the kind of food he thinks
other people want to talk about the kind
he thinks will get him the most
recognition and material success
every 200 years
we get an earthquake
right along the coast
and one's coming up robin tells amir how
an earthquake will eventually destroy
portland and everything they see around
them we could take this as the ranting
of a doomsayer but he specifically says
we don't
have to care he doesn't say that we
shouldn't care he doesn't say that
nothing matters he's telling amir he can
choose what to care about that the
material world is impermanent chef
fenway doesn't have to care about the
things the critics and consumers think
and amir doesn't have to care about what
his father thinks of him he's not
telling derek to give up being a chef
he's asking him why he isn't being
authentic to what he truly believes has
value why do you care about these people
they don't care about you none of them
they don't even know you
because you haven't
shown them
john wick drives a flashy car the son of
the villain envies and steals
robin's junky truck doesn't work
and he has to be driven around in the
villain's flashy car
thank you you live your life for them
and they don't even see you
you don't even see yourself
we don't get a lot of things to really
care about
often lost can make obvious the things
in life that are most valuable in pig
it's not just robin who has lost his
wife were you always like this
was it just after she died darius the
villainous restaurant tour has as well
they are mirrors of each other were you
they both try to avoid the pain of loss
by keeping their partners alive
artificially robin in his mind by
avoiding everything in the world that
reminds him of her and darius medically
neither of them is able to fully let go
and embrace the reality of the situation
when he takes robin's pig darius forces
robin to come back into the city and
confront the reality of what he's lost
and robin's revenge on darius if you can
call it that is in fact an act of
compassion through this dinner that
reminds darius of a happy memory with
his wife he forces darius to also
confront the reality of his loss by
doing something loving and compassionate
for darius he strikes him emotionally in
a way that violence wouldn't have
john wick kills the son of the villain
in retribution for killing his puppy in
contrast robin points a mirror towards
what is really valuable in life and in
return amir is able to guide robin
towards accepting the reality of his
loss
i was thinking
if i never came looking for her
in my head
she'd still be alive
but she wouldn't be
as orpheus nears the surface orpheus
feels that he's been duped that eurydice
isn't really behind him and that the
gods of the underworld lied to him and
as he passes from the underworld back
into the world of the living he looks
back
but eurydice hasn't yet crossed the
threshold out of the underworld and she
vanishes
[Music]
no she wouldn't
i love this line because for robin her
can mean so many things
her could be his restaurant hestia named
after the greek goddess of hearth and
family it could mean his wife
and it could mean his pig who he loved
he can grieve the loss of all those
things but hiding in the woods to keep
them alive in his mind isn't the right
way to face life just like caring only
about image and reputation isn't i'm
okay
robin is forced to encounter what he's
lost that things have changed i don't
think we have a persimmon tree that what
he loved is now gone it's a painful
process but it's one that affirms truth
okay
we can pursue success but material
success on its own just for its own sake
is empty meaningless unfulfilling when
we concern ourselves more with our image
and our reputation and what people think
of us rather than whether our work is
authentic to what we value we lose sight
of why it's worth doing at all we lose
sight of the value of meaningful
relationships and the people around us
we don't have to care about a material
world that will one day pass away and
because of this we have freedom to
choose what to care about so why not
care about the things that really matter
the things that bring life and joy into
our lives rather than striving for the
things that give us the most recognition
from society and the most material
success
john wick leaves his life as an assassin
but the lesson he learns in the first
film is that violence is actually useful
and beneficial he doesn't discover that
the underworld is corrupt and bad for
him to the contrary by entering back
into that world and using his old
methods he's able to accomplish his
goals robin also leaves his life as a
chef and when he returns to that world
he's also able to use his old skills and
his reputation to accomplish his goals
but he discovers not success in that
world but that it no longer holds what
he truly loved eurydice
vanishes
this is better
pig is a beautiful piece of sleight of
hand it engages with the tropes and
narrative features of stories like john
wick and nobody while responding to
those films retributive violent value
systems and asserting one of its own it
replaces an ethic of an eye for an eye
with one of loving your enemies and it
replaces valuing the material world and
reputation with an acceptance of
impermanence
this video is sponsored by mubi a hand
curated streaming cinema with a ton of
great films in its library this weekend
i'll be watching the turing horse on
movie directed by bellatar which was
recommended to me by one of my patrons
mubi is a great place to find films that
it can be difficult to find anywhere
else but it's also a fantastic resource
for actually discovering interesting
films to watch it's the only streaming
service i have where i'll just look
through the library and sometimes watch
random things just because it's on movie
their focus on hand curation means that
if something's in their library it means
that they think it's worth your time
mubi is available around the world and i
can offer my audience an extended 30-day
free trial using the link below go to
movie.com
thomasflight that's
mubi.com
thomasflight or click on the link in the
description or in the video to sign up
for your 30-day extended free trial
[Music]
[Music]
you